Laura is in Fort Wayne hi Laura welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi babe so I
just got my first real time job and I'm
getting ready to move to a new city and
start running on my own and I'm
wondering what percentage of my income
you would recommend spending on rent
like I know your policy for a mortgage
but I didn't know if that was any
different for renting and also if
utility should be included in that
percentage or if that's an additional
expense well the the whole idea is if
you spend your whole check on rent
you've got no money right the less you
spend on rent the more you can save and
invest towards buying a home someday or
towards other things and so you know
it's not how much can I spend it's how
little can I spend because obviously
until you buy something rent is just
you're buying patience you're still you
can save up and pay for stuff so I want
to spend as little as possible and you
know be able to have a reasonably good
life in a safe situation for sure but
never more not counting utilities never
more than 1/4 of your take-home pay just
like with your house payment same same
rule of thumb and the reason is simple
you just don't want to become poor
because of your rent payment you know I
didn't use up all your money that's what
it comes down to so somewhere around the
4th of your take-home pay but on rent
I'd like for it to be a whole lot less
so that you don't keep renting forever
that would be my idea they'll be the
gameplan so hey thanks for the call